- Hello and welcome to a deep
dive into the Nitro System.
My name's Ali Saidi,
I'm a Distinguished Engineer at AWS,
and with me today is Filippo Sironi.
who's a Senior Principal Engineer.
Today, we're going to talk
about the Nitro System
and why we've done things in a certain way
and what benefit you get from that.
So far, in AWS,
we built chips spanning multiple areas
including data center I/O, core compute,
and machine learning infrastructure.
With the Nitro System,
we moved functionality away
from a traditional hypervisor
to our purpose built Nitro Chips.
This started back in 2013
and we were working with a
startup called Annapurna Labs,
which we would later
require a few years later.
And this talk's going to talk
mostly about the Nitro System,
but I want to talk about
the couple other areas
where we're investing in custom silicon.
The second one is with Graviton,
where we build host CPUs
that deliver the best price performance
for a wide range of cloud workloads.
We have a range of customers
running on Graviton,
people like Epic Games, who
are the makers of Fortnite,
Stripe, the payment processing company,
Datadog, and even SAP
running commercial databases.
Some of these customers
are running the majority of their compute
on Graviton today.
And the third place where we've
invested in custom silicon
is our machine learning accelerators.
With Trainium,
and we announced Trainium3
instance availability yesterday,
we built purpose-built
deep learning accelerators
from the ground up
to deliver the best price performance
for machine learning
inference and for training.
So, why do we build our own hardware?
It's not necessarily
easy to build hardware,
but the answer's kind of simple.
We're building our silicon
where we can provide
improved price performance
for our customers.
And there's a couple ways we do this.
One is through specialization.
By building our own chips
we get to specialize the
hardware for AWS use cases
that lets us tailor our designs
to the AWS operating environment
and we can tailor the performance
and the design of them
to our specific needs
and not burden them with many features.
You might ask,
"Why are people burdening
chip ever with any features?"
And the reason is it's
expensive to build silicon.
And so, when companies build it,
they want it to apply to a
bunch of different markets.
And by focusing just on our
use cases, we get to optimize.
So, I'll show you today
how we tailored the Nitro
System to AWS's infrastructure
to improve both the security
and the performance of our servers.
The second is speed.
We get better speed of execution
when we own the end-to-end
development process
from defining the product
all the way through deploying
in our data centers.
We get to bring technology
to customers faster
and shrink the time
between concept and delivery
by hardware and software co-design.
The third is innovation.
When we're building our our chips,
we're building our servers,
we're putting them in our data centers,
we get to innovate
across traditional silos
and that can be really powerful
and let us optimize
in a way that you can't with those silos.
And lastly is security.
Nitro provides us a mechanism
to enhance the security of our servers
through a hardware root of trust,
verification of firmware on the server,
and limiting interactions
with each of our servers
through our narrow set of
authenticated and auditable APIs.
So, Nitro is really a fundamental rethink
about how virtualization in
the cloud should be done.
At its lowest level,
the Nitro System has our Nitro Cards.
These offer networking, storage,
and security functionality.
In the host processor, you
run our Nitro Hypervisor.
And on top of that,
your virtual machines
and your applications,
and I'll talk to you today
about how this separation
has provided better security
and also let us bring
features to you rapidly.
But first, let me rewind a little bit
and talk about how we got here.
It all started with a simple question.
After building EC2 for almost a decade,
if we applied our learnings,
how do we change our server platforms?
And we got lots of suggestions.
There were performance features
like improving throughput,
simplifying the hypervisor,
reducing latency and jitter,
and being able to have
bare metal instances
that looked and felt like
our virtual machines.
And then, there were a
number of security features
like having transparent encryption,
building a hardware root of trust,
removing operator access from our systems,
and having a narrow set of
auditable and authenticated APIs.
Nitro's a combination of
hardware and software.
The chips, we're building in AWS
and we've built six
generations of these chips now.
We introduced Nitro back
in 2017 with a C5 instance,
but we really started back in 2013
when we started with enhanced networking,
moving functionality
away from the hypervisor
onto special-purpose cards.
Over time, we expanded
the I/O that we offer
through our Nitro Cards to
add EBS and our local storage,
and then we built a hypervisor
where we got to remove a
bunch of functionality.
Since 2017, all the EC2
instances that we've launched
have been based on the Nitro System.
So, what is it tangibly?
On the left here, I've
got one of our Nitro Chips
and that's integrated into
one of our Nitro Cards
that you see on the right.
And this is what one
of servers looked like
before the Nitro System.
We had customer instances
and they were running on
top of the hypervisor Xen.
Now, Xen's great but it did a lot.
It did CPU scheduling, device simulation,
network limiters, security
group enforcement,
packet encapsulation,
and quite a bit more.
It even has a full-blown Linux user space
in this privileged Dom0.
And all that functionality
used resources on the host CPU.
So, we started offloading
those capabilities
onto our Nitro Cards.
And the first place we
did that is networking.
So, let's dive into networking.
We have a family of Nitro Cards
across now six generations of chips.
But from the networking point of view,
they all do a very similar thing.
They provide the VPC data plane
offload for our instances.
This is things like ENI attachments,
enforcing security groups,
creating flow logs,
routing, encapsulating packets,
providing you with DHCP and DNS.
All this used to run in our hypervisor
and is now offloaded
into dedicated hardware
on our Nitro Cards.
Most of our Nitro Cards (clears throat)
since the third generation
also enable transparent
256-bit AES encryption
of networking packets in
transit to other instances
without any performance overhead.
(Ali coughing)
And the VPC card presents the ENA device
that you see in your instances today.
The Elastic Network Adapter
is really cool in that
it's been very extensible.
When we first launched ENA,
we had 10 gigabits of networking.
Since then, we went from
25 to 100 to 200 to 300,
and today we have instances
with over 600 gigabits
of networking bandwidth.
And it's kind of really powerful
that with that same ENA device model,
you can have that range of performance.
You can stop an instance on one
machine, move it to another,
and have an order of magnitude
more networking bandwidth
if that's what your application needs.
This card also provides
our Elastic Fabric Adapter.
EFA is a network with
features geared to HPC
and machine learning workloads.
These workloads are special.
Most workloads either need low latency
or they need high bandwidth,
but ML workloads and HPC workloads
tend to need both at the same time.
They want high bandwidth and low latency.
And to build our Elastic Fabric Adapter,
we had to build our own protocol
to transport data across our network.
We call this a scalable
reliable datagram, or SRD.
SRD lets us use multiple paths
through our network simultaneously
to find you low latency
and high bandwidth paths.
Let's talk a little bit more about that.
Traditional network protocols
take a single path through our network
and if there's congestion,
they're relatively slow
to react to failures.
Our networks kinda look
like this. (clears throat)
They are cross-network
and between any two servers,
you can see there's many different paths
that your packets can take.
And with the knowledge of our networks,
we can detect congestion
and we can route around it
at data center scale times,
not at internet scale times.
And this is exactly what we do
with our SRD and our Nitro Cards.
SRD provides a foundation
for using many paths through
our network simultaneously,
allowing us to distribute
bandwidth across those paths
and react quickly to any
congestion, any link issues,
and significantly reduce tail latencies.
These tail latencies
are particularly important
in distributed applications
where the P50 is not
what you're looking for,
but you're looking for
five nine tail latencies.
And let's look at how kind of SRD is used.
So, the first way we used SRD
was with the Elastic Fabric Adapter.
Here, I'm showing scaling
of an HPC workload
where you have, as you increase cores,
you'd expect to also scale linear yearly.
You'd like to be on the red line.
Before EFA, we were on that purple line.
We scaled pretty well to about 400 cores
and then everything tailed off
and actually, we started
scaling negatively.
When we added EFA,
you can see that scaling trend continues.
We've now had four generations of EFA
and we launched the most recent one
with our P6-B200 and GB200 instances.
Now, another place that
expects in-order packets
are TCP flows.
TCP uses packet ordering
to detect congestion.
And so, through our network,
flows get hashed to a single path.
And that single connection, all
the packets flow through it.
Now, sometimes large flows,
even in an over-provisioned network
can end up hashing to the same path,
and there, they can result
in network congestion.
So, what I'm showing
here in the yellow line.
This can result in packet
delays and packet drops,
which causes TCP to back off
and result in some re-transmits,
reducing total throughput,
and everything continues happily.
TCP congestion is generally good,
but it was built for internet scale times.
Other than congestion,
occasionally you can have
a failure in the network,
like a link failure,
and this is what you
see with this red circle
and with this X here.
In this case, TCP doesn't
respond well at all.
You have to wait for a timeout,
reestablish connection, and try again.
So, why not just send this
across multiple paths?
Well, because TCP has that
expectation of in-order delivery,
so with out Nitro Cards,
we also built something
we call ENA Express.
While TCP doesn't handle
out of order segments,
we've offloaded a functionality
of this to our Nitro Cards.
It allows you to send traffic
across multiple paths at once,
either TCP or UDP traffic
over the SRD protocol,
and the Nitro Card takes care
of assembling the packets
into the right order
before delivering it to your application.
And the benefits can be pretty amazing.
The single-flow bandwidth
goes from 5 gigabits up to 25 gigabits,
and we've seen tail
latencies reduced by 85%.
It's really easy to enable ENA Express.
It's a simple configuration.
It's available in the same AZ. (coughs)
Excuse me, and it's
transparent to TCP and UDP.
So, when EC2 started,
we had one gigabit
networks were pretty common
and it was this way for almost a decade.
Today, we've seen a shift to 25 gigabit
to 100 gigabit to 200 gigabit networks.
The increasing base of
bandwidth has been incredible
and if you look at our instances,
this year, we announced CMR AI instances
that have up to 100 gigabits of bandwidth
in our core sets of platforms.
And in our network-optimized
sets of platforms,
we have the C and R8gn instances
that have two 300 gigabit
network interfaces
in a single instance.
So, 600 gigabits of network bandwidth
are available to an
instance if you need it.
Obviously, I was talking
about core instances there.
If you look at our machine
learning instances,
we've gone from 400 gigabits
with a P5 instance back in 2020
up to 6.4 terabits in
a single instance today
with our P6 instances.
(Ali coughing)
Okay, so we talked about networking.
Let's take a minute
and talk about storage.
NVMe is a great standard protocol
with lots of standardized drivers
across different operating
systems, (coughs)
and our Nitro Card exposes
an NVMe interface on one side
and translates those commands
to the EBS data plane on the other side.
This lets us use those Nitro Cards
to encrypt your data in transit
with a hardware engine on the Nitro Cards.
And it means you don't
need to make a trade-off
between performance or encryption.
You get encryption just transparently
if you enable encrypted volumes.
And you might imagine here too,
EBS uses the SRD, that
protocol I just talked about,
to send packets through multiple paths
to where your EBS volumes are located
to reduce tail latencies.
And just like with networking
at the EC2 instance level,
you can see the amazing
increase in performance
that we've offered over the years.
If you go back a decade,
we had two gigabits of EBS bandwidth.
Today, we offer up to 150
gigabits of EBS bandwidth
and up to 720,000 IOPS
in a single instance.
This lets you run things
like demanding databases
while also having the durability
and enterprise features of EBS.
Now, EBS is great.
It's the answer for
most customers, I think.
You get durability, you get snapshots,
but there are some customers
who also want local storage.
So, let's talk a little
bit about our Nitro SSDs.
And to do that,
I need to tell you a little
bit about how an SSD works.
There's a couple of components in an SSD.
The first is the NAND.
This is where the bits are stored,
but NAND has a lot of peculiarities.
You can only write it after you erase it
and the chunks that you tend
to erase are about a megabyte.
So, even if you want to
update just a single byte,
you actually need to copy
the data to a new location
with an update.
And so, this ends up,
(Ali coughing)
excuse me, needing something
that looks a lot like a
write-locking database.
NAND also has a lifetime.
If you write it a bunch,
write one block a bunch,
you'll wear it out.
So, you need to spread the
writes around all that flash.
And to manage this complexity,
there's something called
a Flash Translation Layer.
It's usually a chip on an SSD.
It maps the logical addresses
that an operating system knows about
to the physical blocks where the NAND is.
It performs garbage collection,
it performs wear leveling,
and ultimately, you end up doing something
like these databases, like
a write-locking database.
Now, there's lots of flash manufacturers
that produce their own
SSDs with their own FTLs.
Just like with databases, actually,
each of those FTL implementations
behaves a bit differently
even though they all offer
the same external API.
They all do a good job
in the average case,
but our experience over many years
is they have some unpredictable behaviors.
Garbage collection decides to kick in
just at the worst possible time.
And these unexpected
behaviors make it hard for us
to engineer a consistent performance.
So, how can we get the
performance we need?
Well, you could probably
guess by this point,
we integrated the FTL
into our Nitro Cards.
And so, with this, we have
up to 60% lower latencies,
improved reliability,
and through our Nitro Cards,
we can encrypt all your data
within an ephemeral key that
never leaves the server.
So, this is what the server now looks like
after we moved a bunch of functionality
away from the host CPU
onto our Nitro Cards.
You can see that Dom0, that
privileged domain, and Xen
is significantly offloaded
and most of the functions
are now handled by the Nitro System.
Now, I'm going to turn it over to Filippo.
He's going to talk to you
about the Nitro Hypervisor
and some of the other features
we offer in the Nitro System.
- Thank you, Ali.
So, let's now look at
the Nitro Hypervisor.
After having offloaded
I/O to dedicated hardware
and purpose-built hardware,
what we're left with
is the bare minimum that
a hypervisor needs to do.
This means focusing on CPU,
memory, and device assignment.
With device assignment,
I mean providing a path
for the virtual CPUs to have direct access
to the dedicated hardware that
we just added to our systems.
On top of that,
we want to make sure that we
strip down the hypervisor,
removing every other feature
that's not necessary.
For example,
when hypervisor isn't involved
with networking or storage,
we can get rid of the network stack,
we can get rid of the storage stack,
so no more file system support.
We can also get rid of additional services
like the SSH server
to make sure that access
to the hypervisor,
which is the closest
component to customer data,
is completely restricted.
This results in a very small, lightweight,
and secure hypervisor,
a hypervisor that's quiescent
and it's only going to execute code
whenever the customer instance
asks for hypervisor services.
Think about instruction
emulation, for example.
And when you put this all together,
you have a hypervisor
that provides very minimal
performance overhead
such that our virtual machines
can have close to bare metal performance.
If you take a look at
our most recent series
of virtual machines and
bare metal machines,
it's very difficult to find differences
in terms of performance between our metal
and our virtualized instances.
Beyond stripping down the
hypervisor to the bare minimum,
we also wanted to go one step further.
The hypervisor runs at a layer of the CPU
where it normally has
access to everything.
It's the most,
is the highest priority component
that normally has access to all the CPU
and all the memory in our system.
However, this violates one of
the main security principles,
which is the principle of least access.
So we want to make sure,
with the Nitro Hypervisor,
we wanted to make sure that the hypervisor
was not going to have
access to any customer data
unless it really needed to.
When you look at the commodity hypervisor,
it owns the entire address
space of the server.
When you start a virtual machine,
both the CPU context,
which means all the CPU
registers as well as the memory
is part of the hypervisor address space,
which means that the
hypervisor has full access.
This holds for all the virtual
machines that we start.
When we look at the Nitro Hypervisor,
the address space of the
Nitro Hypervisor is minimal.
We are talking about
hundreds of megabytes,
the bare minimum to run our systems.
Whenever we start a virtual machine,
both the CPU context and the
memory for that virtual machine
are outside of the address
space of the hypervisor.
This gives us great properties
because whenever there is
a bug in the hypervisor
or for example a CPU security problem,
we have better properties
that allow us to reason about
whether customer data
would be in reach or not.
This is true for all the virtual machines
that we start on our server.
Each one gets its own address space
and whenever the hypervisor
needs to perform services
on behalf of a virtual machine,
for example instruction emulation,
what happens is the hypervisor
maps the bare minimum amount of memory
that's necessary to perform its operation.
And as soon as that's done,
the hypervisor goes back
to having its previous address space
that does not map any
of the customer data.
We call this type of memory management
secret hiding.
Since then,
since we started our journey,
implemented secret hiding by
removing memory and CPU context
from the hypervisor address space,
this has also been called design
of a secret-free hypervisor
or in some cases,
people are referring to
inability of hypervisor
to access customer data
as confidential computing.
A few months ago,
a research group from
a university in Europe
published a very interesting
piece of research
talking about a new security vulnerability
called L1TF Reloaded.
L1TF Reloaded
is a transit execution attack
that relies on L1TF
and what researchers
call half-Spectre gadget.
So, it's one attack
that derives from Spectre Meltdown
that came in 2018.
Through the clever combination of L1TF
and half-Spectre gadgets,
the research team was able to show
that when running on a commodity Linux KVM
and KVM hypervisor as well
as other cloud providers,
it was possible to
exfiltrate the private keys
of a web server from
one instance to another.
On the other end, when the
same attack was mounted
against the two instances
running on the Nitro Hypervisor,
the researchers were not able
to extract any of the private keys
and this is thanks to the design
of a secret-free hypervisor.
We recently published a blog post
with a deep dive into memory management
of the Nitro Hypervisor.
I invited you to scan
the QR code on the screen
and take another look at the blog post.
Now, let's continue our
journey on the security aspect
of the Nitro System.
The next component in the Nitro System
that has to do with security
is the Nitro Security Chip.
The Nitro Security Chip
is a piece of silicon
that's baked on our motherboard
and helps the primary Nitro
Card or the Nitro Controller
establishing a hardware root of trust.
If you look at motherboards,
they have a series of
non-volatile assets, flashes.
These flashes contain BIOS, UEFI images,
or the binary image of the BMC,
the BMC being the component
that manages the fan speed
and collects several information
about the system like the
temperature, voltages, and so on
to guarantee that the system
is operating correctly.
Through the Nitro Security Chip,
we are able to consistently
and continuously monitor the content
of the flashes on our systems
and we do this for two purposes.
First, we want to be able
to update them out of band
to make sure that we always
have the latest software running
in our fleet.
And on top of that, we
are able to validate
that the software
and the firmware that we
are running on our systems
is exactly what we intend to run.
Beyond that, the Nitro Security Chip
keeps monitoring the auxiliary
buses on our systems.
Think like the I2C bus
or the SPI bus to access flashes.
Okay, we have removed I/O,
we have moved the management of security.
We basically stripped down
Dom0 to the bare minimum,
potentially removing it,
and we designed a new hypervisor,
a hypervisor that's
quiescent and lightweight
and that gives more
resources to customers,
translates into higher performance.
On top of that,
we have a very flexible
system in the Nitro System.
Because the Nitro System
is extremely composable,
we can increase the number
of Nitro Cards in our servers
to provide more local storage
to provide higher performance
for remote storage or
higher network performance.
If you look at our pace of launches
in terms of instance types
between 2006 and 2017,
we launched 17 instance types.
However, after the full Nitro
System has been developed
and put in production in 2017,
we have since launched more
than 800 instance types,
to the point where we are
at 1,000 plus instance types today,
and we did stop counting.
Okay, let's continue our
journey into the Nitro System
and keep focusing on the security aspects.
So, security is the number
one priority for AWS,
but security is also a
shared responsibility.
There is security of the cloud
and security in the cloud
that we need to take care of.
AWS is responsible for
security of the cloud
and this starts from
securing our facilities
and making sure that our
hardware is in top shape.
The firmware and the software
that runs on our hardware
is exactly what we intend to run.
On the other end, the customer
is responsible for the
security in the cloud.
This means that the customer
is responsible for updating
the operating system
that runs in their instances,
making sure that their application
are using all the very latest libraries,
for example, cryptographic libraries
that are not subject to timing attacks.
And on top of that,
customers are responsible
for using all the security
features that we make available
like VPC, security groups,
and configuring them correctly
to prevent instances
that are not supposed
to talk with one another
from communicating.
Okay, let's continue our
journey on the security front
and let's talk about
confidential computing.
Confidential computing
is something that popped
up a couple of years ago
and it tries to specify
how to protect customer
code and customer data.
There's been a bit of confusion
and I want to address a few
topics on on this front.
At AWS, we really believe
that confidential computing
is all about making sure
that customer data and code is protected,
but we need to understand
from whom this needs to be protected.
We have two dimensions here
that we need to consider.
The first dimension is
protecting customer code and data
from the cloud provider itself
and from one customer to the next.
When it comes to the cloud provider,
the Nitro System
provides several improvements
because we removed operator
access to the Nitro System
and to the Nitro Hypervisor.
So, we make sure that
customer data is safe
and customer code as well.
Now, let's recap how the
Nitro System achieves that.
We have encryption for all
the communication channels
where customer data may be in transit.
We use Secure Boot and
Measured Boot extensively
to ensure that our hardware
is running the latest
firmware and software
and most importantly,
the firmware and software
that we intend to run,
and we perform cryptographic validation
that this is the case
from the very early stages
of the boot process.
On top of that, we have
periodic deployments
of newer version of firmware and software
to patch our systems,
to have the latest security fixes,
the latest bug fixes.
This includes all the firmware
and software that we run,
including the Nitro Hypervisor,
which we can live update
with no interruption
of customer workloads.
Lastly, as I mentioned before,
we got rid of access to our servers.
There is no shell,
no SSH to the Nitro System
and to the Nitro Hypervisor.
Beyond that,
every piece of software
and firmware that we build,
it's built by multiple teams
that are globally distributed
across all the continents
and it is code reviewed
by multiple people,
extensively tested,
and only when all our testing is passing,
this code is production signed
to make sure that the
EC2 deployments service
can deploy it following our policy
across all the AZs and
regions that AWS provides.
Now, let's take a look
at the second dimension
of confidential computing.
We want to provide options to customers
to make sure that the
customer code and data
is also protected within
the customer organization.
There are several levels
of trustworthiness of software
that we usually deploy,
that anybody deploys in systems.
There are highly trusted pieces
of code that, for example,
operate on signing keys
and there are less trusted piece of code
that provide public endpoints.
We want to make sure
that these are decoupled
so that a bug in a piece of code
that deals with a public endpoint
does not result in leaking
a signing key, for example.
One of the solutions that
we offer on this front
is Nitro Enclaves.
With Nitro Enclaves,
the parent instance is
able to donate resources
in terms of CPU and memory
and these resources are
used by the hypervisor
to start a sidecar instance.
These sidecar instance or enclaves
has all the security
properties of an EC2 instance.
It benefits for all the
secret hiding that I mentioned
that Nitro Hypervisor
implements, for example.
However, it's also a much
more enclosed environment
because a Nitro Enclave does
not have persistent storage,
does not have a network
interface, for example.
It only has a thin pipe
between itself and the parent instance,
so that the parent instance
can provide commands
for perform our PC calls, for example.
Nitro Enclaves are integrated with AWS KMS
and when all the software
in the Nitro Enclaves
is attested,
an attestation document can
be used together with KMS
to unlock content that only
the enclave needs to access.
And one of the most common
use case for Nitro Enclaves
is to store signing keys, for example.
Beyond Nitro Enclaves,
we are also providing
features like Secure Boot.
Now,
A-M-Is or AMIs provide an immutable way
to boot software on an EC2 instance.
However, there is a lot of use
of UEFI Secure Boot on-premise
and customers have been asking us
to provide the very same
features for EC2 instances.
Through UEFI Secure Boot,
it is possible for the
guest firmware, UEFI,
to cryptographically validate
that the boot loader and the kernel
and the rest of the operating system
that's going to be loaded,
it is signed with a key
that the customer trusts.
This allows the customer
to protect against a type of malware
that may persist across reboots
and ensures that an EC2 instance
will only run the software that
the customer intends to run.
NitroTPM is the next step on this journey.
NitroTPM is a TPM 2.0 implementation
that conforms to the standard
and it allows
measurement of software,
cryptographic measurement of software,
and extending this
measurement into the TPM
so that this measurement can be used to,
for example, unlock the local
storage on an EC2 instance
using solutions like LUKS or BitLocker.
Now, UEFI Secure Boot and Nitro and TPMs
are available since a long while.
However, the software
stack to make use of them
has historically been complicated.
Having end-to-end
attestation of a workload
is not a simple step,
and that is why customers
love Nitro Enclaves.
Nitro Enclaves provide an easy solution
to validate that the entire software
that's being running the workload
is exactly what it's supposed to be.
So, customer ask us
to port this ease-of-use
to EC2 instances as well
for use cases where Nitro
Enclaves are not enough.
That's why we released the
EC2 instance attestation.
Now, EC2 instance attestation
builds on top of UEFI Secure
Boot and the Nitro TPM
and makes use of what we
are calling Attestable AMIs.
Attestable AMIs are AMIs that
can be built over and over
and rebuilding those
AMIs following a recipe
will always result in the
same bits that we can measure.
And again, we can use those measurement
to provide an attestation document,
an attestation document that
like with Nitro Enclaves
can be used to work with
AWS KMS to unlock secrets.
What can EC2 instance attestation
be used for?
One of the use cases that we have in mind
is confidential inferencing.
Think about the case of a cloud provider
wanting to make a closed-source
machine learning model,
AI/ML model available to customers.
Now, the model provider
may not want to disclose the model weights
because those are the IP of
of the model provider, right?
And the cloud provider wants to make sure
that the customer data,
meaning the prompts and
the inferred content,
will not be available
to the model provider.
Now, EC2 instance attestation
allows us to build systems
that achieve these guarantees.
EC2 instance attestation
is available on a large
range of Nitro instances
including AI/ML instances
with premium Inferentia
accelerators as well as Nvidia GPUs.
And you can start building UEFI
and Nitro TPM-enabled Attestable AMIs
using Amazon Linux 2023 or NixOS,
and this is working for both Graviton,
AMD, and Intel instances.
A few years back,
we published a white paper
discussing the security
design of the AWS Nitro System
and where we go in more depth
into security aspects of the design
of the Nitro Cards and
the Nitro Hypervisor
and the Nitro Security Chip.
In addition, the NCC group,
which is an independent company,
perform a review of the Nitro System
including all the APIs
that EC2 Control Plane
or any operator can use
to work with the Nitro System,
and thus concluded that
there is no mechanism
for a cloud operator
to gain access to the underlying host
or to the customer data
that's stored in the instance
memory, instance storage,
or EBS volumes.
I invite you to scan the QR code
and have a look at the
white paper in depth.
Now, let's continue our
journey into the Nitro System
and let's look at a Graviton4 server.
This is a server that can
run many virtual machines
or one or two bare metal instances.
When we run two bare metal instances,
the lifecycle of the two CPUs is decoupled
even though they share
a single Nitro System.
When looking at this server,
all the high-speed connections, the DRAM,
everything is encrypted.
DRAM encryption is something
that we started doing
with our sixth generation
of instance families,
leading with Graviton2.
And since then,
all EC2 instance platforms
have used DRAM encryption.
With our eighth generation
of Nitro instances,
again leading with Graviton4 this time,
we also started encrypting the links
that connect the CPU to the
Nitro Cards using PCIe IDE,
but with Graviton4 we
went one step further.
Graviton4 is the first Graviton solution
where we are supporting multiple sockets,
so up to two CPUs in a server
communicating with one another,
and the coherency link
between the two CPUs
are also encrypted.
Now, for the cloud to be secure,
we have to have certainty
of everything that's running
and we have to make sure
that at any time,
we have a cryptographic certainty
of all the software and firmware
that we're running on our servers.
That's what we call attestation.
However, doing these at the scale of AWS,
it's a challenging problem.
Let's take a look at
how an EC2 server boots
or any server boot for what matters.
When the silicon is light up,
it loads code from the code from the ROM,
the ROM will instruct the
CPU on how to load firmware
and then the firmware
will hand over control
to the boot loader,
which usually resides on the boot volume.
And the boot loader
is further concerned with
loading the operating system
and from there, loading
the customer application.
Now, at every time when
we hand over control
from one piece of firmware
or software to the next,
there is a chance that
something may go wrong.
So, we have to make sure
that every single step
of the boot process is validated.
But where do we start?
We need to start from the very beginning,
from the manufacturing plans,
and we have to follow
our hardware
from manufacturing through
the assembly lines,
transits from the assembly
lines to our data centers,
installation in our data centers
and power on in our data centers.
This is about creating
an unbroken chain of custody
and verification of
every piece of hardware,
firmware, and software
that runs on our servers.
Now, let's dive specifically
into how this works
for our most recent Graviton4 servers,
and it all starts with a Nitro Chip.
Every Nitro Chip
comes with a private and a public key,
and this couple of private and public keys
allow us to establish a chain of trust.
At every step of the boot process,
we use this to create a new
pair of private and public key,
destroying the previous pair,
and making sure that the next
piece of software that we load
is exactly what we intend it to be.
With Graviton, though, we
push this one step further.
We do not just look at
the Nitro System itself.
What happens is that the same idea
of having a private and a public key
extends to the CPUs in our systems.
And this allows us to make sure
that only two CPUs
that are two Graviton4 CPUs
can talk with one another
and we can establish
a cryptographic channel
between the two of them
whenever we are running
coherency between the two CPUs.
Also, we can establish a secure link
between the Nitro System,
meaning all the Nitro Cards
that we have in our systems
and the CPUs, again relying on PCIe IDE.
Now, let's put everything together
and let's look at the life
cycle of an EC2 instance.
Whenever a customer calls run instance,
the run instance call
will go through the EC2 Control Plane.
All the necessary resources
will be made available
by the control plane,
but the last mile of the control plane
will use the Nitro API,
which is an authenticated,
authorized, encrypted,
and most importantly, logged API
that's going to instruct the
Nitro System on what to do.
The first step is for the control plane
to tell the Nitro Controller
to allocate an empty shell,
which only contains CPU and memory.
The Nitro Controller will do so
by making an RPC to the Nitro Hypervisor
so that the Nitro Hypervisor
can perform the allocation.
The next step is for
these two control plane
to instruct the Nitro Controller
to set up the Nitro Cards
so that we can expose
ENI through ENA devices
and EBS volumes through NVMe.
The Nitro Controller will later
on instruct the hypervisor
to create a channel
between the virtual CPUs
and the dedicated hardware
to make sure that the hypervisor
will not be in the picture
whenever there is an I/O happening.
The last step is for the EC2 Control Plane
to tell the Nitro Controller
to start the virtual machine.
At this point,
the Nitro Controller will
instruct the hypervisor,
the hypervisor will start
executing the guest firmware,
and from the guest firmware,
the boot loader and guest kernel
and guest operating system
will be loaded.
And again, potentially
using a UEFI Secure Boot
and Nitro TPM and so on.
On a Graviton4 server,
whenever we are running
in non-coherent mode,
this could happen at any
time on any of the two hosts.
And most critically,
this also works whenever the hypervisor
is not in the picture.
And this relies on the Nitro Controller
and the Nitro Security Chip
holding the CPU in a reset state
so that the EC2 Control Plane
and the Nitro Controller
and the Nitro Cards
can set up the system
so that the ENA devices
and NVMe devices exposing
the EBS root volume
become available to the CPU,
so that the CPU can start
booting the metal instance
as soon as it is released from reset.
And the very same solution
is what enabled AWS
to also bring Mac into the cloud.
If you're familiar with our offering,
we have multiple
iteration of Mac instances
and in this case, we
connect the Nitro System
to Apple Mac Minis
using a PCIe to Thunderbolt connector.
And this allows us to
provide the elasticity,
reliability, and security
of EC2 to Mac users,
including EBS volumes, VPC,
and every other feature that AWS provides.
This is a great option
for customers that are
building applications
for macOS, iOS, tvOS, watchOS,
and they need to perform
continuous builds,
testing, and signing
of their applications.
And with this, we are concluding our talk.
We are happy to take
question outside of the room.
Thank you for your attendance.
(audience clapping)